Good morning, John.
Do you ever worry that all of the wonderful
things that, uh, occupy the space in our lives
are built on, uh, human suffering and misery?
So a couple of weeks ago, Katherine and I
were on a little mini-vacation at a hot spring
in Jackson, Montana. A very small town, uh,
just the hot spring pretty much; that's all
that's there. We were on our way home and
we noticed a big sign for a thing and we were
like, "Well, we got a whole day to drive home,
let's look at the thing!"
My hair looks extremely good today. I want
my hair to look like this forever. I look
like Topher Brink from -- from The Dollhouse.
That's... What a horribly nerdy thing to want
to look like. Oh my goodness.
Anyway, we saw the sign, and we wanted to
stop, and that is how I learned about the
Nez Perce War, the last of the Indian wars
in America. I've never had a particularly
good conception of what Native Americans were
like in eighteen hundreds in the west. There
are sort of two prevailing views: There's
the cowboys and Indians one where we're shooting
each other, and then there's the New Age-y,
in touch with the earth, seventh generation,
use all of the buffalo, nomadic wanderer idea.
And there's probably elements of truth in
both of those, but what I would not have thought
is that Native Americans in the west in the
eighteen hundreds were both powerful and rich.
Now, I'm not talking about wisdom and spirituality;
I'm talking about militarily powerful and
economically rich. In fact, they were much
better fighters than the American cavalry,
and the numbers in these battles reflect that.
There were far more American cavalry members
who died than Native Americans.
What the Nez Perce Indians did economically
was really remarkable. In the fifty years
between when white settlers started showing
up and this last Indian war, the Nez Perce
were able to use the resources they had at
their disposal, their land and their knowledge
of their land, in combination with entirely
new technologies like horses and guns, and
carve out an extremely valuable and unique
niche in the American economy, which was making
really great horses for the American West.
That wasn't all that they did, but that was
sort of what they were famous for, and it
made a lot of Nez Perce very wealthy, and
it made a lot of Nez Perce tribes very powerful.
So let's go real quick to the board. The board
is something that I've been experimenting
with. The board!
So I just wanted to give you an idea of what
caused the Nez Perce war. This is the original
homeland of the Nez Perce, and then this was
the original treaty that the United States
government had with the Nez Perce. This was
their, uh, agreed upon homeland. However,
the fact that this area contained lots of
good cattle range and later they discovered,
actually, lots of gold, became very problematic.
So partially because the United States feared
letting the Nez Perce get their hands on this
gold and continuing to have this extremely
valuable resource in the form of land, the
United States compelled by force the Nez Perce
to sign another treaty that gave them this
land. Obviously, not a good deal, and many
of the Nez Perce tribes decided not to sign
that treaty.
These are the tribes that we ended up going
to war with. This is where Katherine and I
were that day at the site of the Battle of
the Big Hole in the beautiful Big Hole Valley
where the Nez Perce were ambushed. They had
no idea that this force was after them. They
were attacked during the night. The vast majority
of losses were women and children and the
elderly stuck in their teepees as General
Gibbon's force rode through their camp.
To me, of course, hundreds of years later,
this does not look like a battlefield; it
just looks like a beautiful valley. We seem
kind of obsessed, uh, with remembering the
places where we lost battles. But I think
it's probably more important, actually, for
the future of our culture and even maybe our
species, that we remember the places where
we lost something more than that.
Like, for example, our humanity and our ability
to tell when we're doing something wrong.
In this valley a nation of strong and wise
people lost their lives, their families, their
possessions, their homes, everything that
they owned. They lost those things to greed,
to complacency, to prejudice, and they lost
those things not because they were weak but
because they were strong.
That's something that I think it worth remembering
every once in a while, John, I'll see you
on Friday.